die letzte show des jahres gehört den
regionalen künstlern
es ist die populärste ausstellung aber
auch die umstrittenste vorstellig werden
wenn dort ab 200 liegt gegen einen der
hauptgründe
es war knapp sagte fixplatz mehrheit für
ihn dazu
das ist offenkundig das aufwendige
projekt also grossaufmarsch aber
einräumen dass sie gar nicht das leisten
die auswahl 18 wie eine
jahresausstellung entsteht
[Musik]
die auswahl 18 das ist die plattform für
regionales kunstschaffen eine jury wählt
aus und ab dann ist das die
mammut-aufgabe der kuratorin sie muss
aus diesen vielen vielen werken eine
ausstellung machen die so richtig nach
was ausschaut und das allein erscheint
mir bereits eine hohe kunst zu sein
wir kommen auf den platz
[Musik]
die künstler um einen platz in der
jahresausstellung kämpfen und wie die
jury auswählt wir waren dabei
immer im herbst treffen im aargauer
kunsthaus die dossiers die bewerbungen
für die jahresausstellung heim
hier wird die jury für die auswahl 1802
tag werden
nun wird es dann auch mit rumgekriegt
diskutieren welche positionen mir dann
am schluss führten die zuständige vier
menschen entscheiden über kunst und
deren qualität
die verantwortliche kuratorin simone
choo choo der künstler markus weggenmann
der kurator daniel morgenthaler und die
künstlerin andrea xxi es ist sie monat
schoss erste ausstellung für das
aargauer kunsthaus
sie ahnt nicht wie viele stunden sie
noch mit ihren kollegen hier sitzen wird
dringend um die kunst was hier
ausgewählt wird füllt danach zwei
stockwerke des kunsthauses
ich glaube die jahresuhr stellige die
sind sehr stark identitätsstiftend für
künste fürs publikum euro sie lebt es
sich wie auf es ist es wo es noch
stärker verankert region mich ein
treffen mit der künstlerin strähnen von
dauer sagte ganze große facetten auf
funktionen das ganze sie ist eine der
165 kunstschaffenden die für die auswahl
18 ein dossier eingereicht haben
ich bewerbe mich für fußball achter will
ich mich freue der mini neueste arbeit
eine grössere schweizer publikum zeigt
werden
der täglich vor deren arbeit ich es gibt
kein richtiges leben im falschen
und gott verrußt dass bei einzelnen sehr
wenig ausrichten
im system von grund auf falsch ist es
schwieriges richtig glauben
für ihre ich kann eigentlich frei
fluktuierend zeichnet das concept car
was groovt und einzige was mir wichtig
ist humor will beruflich über die wahl
dankes kurz mittel zum hof reagieren wie
jetzt nehme im innern zerstört weil ich
nicht um große freude wenn ich ihnen
aber sich nehmen so also am anfang und
profiliert gegangen ist das für mich das
risiko maxi wenn ich hab die antwort bin
und hört kann ich das
werden es die täler von christine hunold
auf den stapel schaffen und somit teil
der ausstellung sein
am zweiten tag sind bereits 50 dossiers
mit einem c versehen
sprich aussortiert erkennt das
irritation moment nicht und ich kann
auch nichts gesagt all das ist aggressiv
woher kommt das spiel gelegt genau das
gestalterische serie beenden ich finde
das ist einfach mit präzis ich möchte
wie sich die perspektiven für die grünen
schlagen künstlerisches aufs herz wer
abgelehnt wird und es ist halt das
bewusst sie das ist wirklich so ist dass
das wirklich sehr verletzend quasi das
macht vielleicht mit dem ästhetisch
damit befindet sich das waren aber wo
dann natürlich noch einen schritt weiter
gehen
längst sollte die jury in der
schlussrunde sein sollte aber statt
abendessen gibt es nun videokunst genau
das hatten wir uns eigentlich sowieso
schon gebraucht gemacht hat sie hat ein
[Musik]
brasilianischer architekt sie sich nicht
damit beschäftigt schwabach ist elano
war das ist wo man nicht so gut kennt
es ist sehr anfällig macht es das selbe
90 die musik musik das könnte
mit
[Musik]
ich bin für orenburg sind die dresdner
alt ich mache bei der auswahl 18 mit
völlig neue arbeit zeigen hier so
präsentiert haben und erhoffe mir mit
ihrer arbeit ein berg betrug die
künstlerin will also einen platz in der
jahresausstellung und finanzielle
unterstützung vom kanton bekommen mit
der komplexen und sehr grosszügig brauch
ja
für mich ganz wichtig das video zum
sowie der sinnlichkeit mitgefühl davor
architektur mit minimaler sachen stil
wieso natur wo sich bewegt oder das
gefühl von der architektur sich etwa
junge twitter machen und falls ich jetzt
ein werk betrag wird über könnte ich das
wiso finanzieren
der zeitabschnitt von 30 bis 40
antworten muss es passieren aber man
muss in der galerie sie irgendwo die
zuständige kammer habe und dann setze
ich laufen oder irgendwo versickert und
da war es natürlich ein wenig mit dem
beton co
[Musik]
foto jury hat stress mit den sinn dass
es eine ganz komische dynamik geben
und was macht sich allein gestellt
ja
ja es ist ein gewinn
ja ich finde es jetzt an der sound macht
es für die gute bild und text sie nicht
wenn wir schon so häufig die architektur
ist also die brasilianische architektur
ich bin mir nicht so gut kennen sie
nicht
aber es hatte malta wo man hat das
gefühl jetzt eine neue hand noch
irgendwie ihre brasilianische architekt
entdeckt könnte danach fiel mit 395
neueste zwölf zähler oder musik also was
machen wir jetzt machen wir also fix
schon vor sie forschen eine region auf
die videos konsequente nächste sagte
widerruf erlecke wichtig finden und dass
ich besser so dass der otto stelle dann
macht eva riede jurys und schob der
juryarbeit auch durch stelle gedankt wie
das alles war sie wo qualität sondern
auch aus dem ganz murcia nach
einstelligen stausee gemacht jetzt kann
nur das als könig jetzt musst du dich
entscheiden
ich finde so also ich finde der moment
wo mit dem reset lied und irgendwie
gleichzeitig aber dafür sind die
primarschulen center und das schwein
also aber also was hat der papst aber
dass ich es dann nicht sagen die jury
unter zeitdruck
noch immer sind rund 80 positionen im
rennen was ist innovativ was frisch was
braucht die ausstellung elf stunden
schon wird diskutiert bewertet
ausgewählt schwierigkeiten schneller
habe jetzt nicht aufbewahrt die wahrhaft
setzen dass wir das schaffen rief das
ist normal
das kriterium ob man die spiele ich bin
ich dagestanden und befindet sich ganz
besonders allen die für mich infrage
kommt ich war das jahre werk aus der
serie landschaft im rückspiegel
zusammengestellt
landschaften im rückspiel und gemüt
meine ich nicht wirklich idee dass man
im rückspiel condor geht und ihn nur
sondern einfach wie das was uns die
ganze zeit beschäftigt das mir
unglaublich bombardiert werden vorbilder
und um die ganze zeit bilder ja ist
nicht hüpfen und die alle sicherlich
vermischt und zurück bliebe zur fragment
wahrnehmung und erinnerung
[Musik]
was ich wann wird lehre zum
körpervolumen wenn es zum loch die
mobile der ihnen schwerer die
leerstellen einstellen da eigentlich im
haupthaus das ist in dieser neuen
flecken auf der landkarte von der worden
war
[Musik]
innerhalb wurde deutsch wird ist es sind
die jahres und stelle ich schon sehr
wichtig das sind immer die einzige ort
wo man sich ja zeigen es gibt immer
weniger galerien im moment ische großes
galeria sterben im gang
ich danke wenn man ab und zu jeder
hersteller brisant ist ein existiert man
als kunstschaffende person wie immer
absolut wo nicht irgendwann einmal
wieder der duft auch die verschwindet
[Musik]
das habe ich mir einfach dass ich sicher
bin mit dem was ich liebe das land ist
aber bliebe aber wie sicher ist sich die
jury mit dem lokalmatador
er ist engagiert und probiert aber das
können wir zum beispiel also was
kreiswerke stimmt ja vorstellte sind
sind laut lüthi das gemacht
ja und respektvolle umgang nicht nur mit
dem was da ist sondern mit dem was nicht
mit dem wasser der respekt gegenüber
demjenigen derjenige tag für tag ist
delikat und unter bis er schafft alles
ist in der struktur und konnte dadurch
sozusagen das ist mir wichtig zu
platzieren und einfach dazu ich bin
fokussiert ruft dass es irgendwann
fertig werden dass ich nicht mehr
also ich gespielt und religion gehe es
auch um eine hand wie viel haben
ich finde es plötzlich unsicher
ja aber es wird zur bliebe der oper an
dem unrecht worden ist und mir manches
eine möglichkeit der oma karin jetzt ist
es dass alfie oder und zwei tag
tragkraft und eigentlich wir haben aber
ob er nur ein tag mit werden moderne
kreft
zwei wochen später post aus veronika
sparrenburg erfährt ob sie bei der
jahresausstellung dabei ist und ob sie
sogar unterstützung bekommt
es freut uns sehr ihnen mitteilen zu
können dass sie von der jury des
auggener kunst als es mit ihrem
ausstellungs vorschlag in die
ausstellung aus orten abgenommen wurden
ach so also die handschuhe entscheidet
dass ich nicht für den förderwerk betrag
auf knapp oder bin ja noch gut dran ist
ja eine frau ja die liebe das geld
seit kurzem passion erfreut und auch
oliver krähenbühl ist bei der auswahl
dabei
das toll dass mir dabei kann zeigen in
dem rahmen und und die arbeitgeber jetzt
wieder auf wanderschaft licht sehen was
jetzt folgt sind zehn tage aufbau der
ausstellung
[Musik]
53 kunstwerke ohne übergeordnetes
leitthema gilt es zu platzieren und sie
monat schon kennt die räume bisher nur
als besucherin beim muss macht man es um
große plan und das ist eigentlich das
schönste spiel für mich ist das axiom
mit dir die arbeiten unter die riemen
herz tauschte und da ist das karriere
wie viel platz braucht bis berlin
nachbarschaft er vertraut und doch was
mein geschäft liebling aber das service
andere weil sie das werk sei für sich
selber gelegt werden
[Musik]
das basic groß dass ich nicht unbedingt
denn muss nicht um sexy dass ich einfach
mal ruhe vielleicht kann man dann am
start erwartet doch mal ab und ich muss
aber gott zum dass mir vorstellen
[Musik]
das wird ja ich weiß nicht wer kommt und
ich weiß nicht wie viel platz das selbe
wie viel luft dazwischen
das geht gar nicht das ist scheiße
seit dem moment geben der umzug wie
sachen connect an der uni das
traditionell dass ich völlig verliert
und dann einfach so die hilflosigkeit
dass man merkt man nicht ganz die high
wie die meisten künstler bringt auch
oliver krähenbühl seine werke persönlich
vorbei die frage wo das kunstwerk im
raum positioniert wird ist essentiell
der winkel ist sowieso und ich glaube es
müsste jetzt nochmal zwischen den
völkern und jetzt noch mal acht zurück
und der winkel noch mal und durchaus
anspruchsvoll
zuletzt schlug staunten auch das
klangerlebnis ist entscheidend bei dem
kunstwerk die schafe sind weg von sonja
krätz braucht es mehrere anläufe
wahrscheinlich muss man denn der winkel
noch nie andere oder ich weiß es noch
nicht so genau
im untergeschoss schallt veronika
spielen burgs installation durch alle
räume die macher stolz wenig
dransfeld ja
das macht ratlos gewirkt hat und viele
da müsste mir wahrscheinlich habe ich
dann freundlich mit den anderen da was
passiert sowas gut
[Musik]
nebenan werden die schafe noch immer
verschoben weil sich eine verbindung mit
der business gott wirklich was das
eigenständig stadt das nicht verloren
wirkt der rumänische doch recht groß
wenn es kühl an dass gott noch besser
dann versuche ich das buch zu
perfektionismus aber ist gut und was ich
sehr schön findest du mit deiner
verschiedenen aussichten
das ist sehr schön
und am ende hängt auch der krähenbühl an
seinem finalen platz
[Musik]
der große tag 500 leute sind gekommen
bei einer vernissage waren es 2018 mehr
auch mit dabei die künstlerin christine
hunold die nicht teil der auswahl 18 ist
den anstoss
für veronika scherenburg gibt es noch
eine überraschung
sie erhielt keine werkbeitrag dafür hat
das museum ihre arbeit für die sammlung
angekauft
na ja nichts wissen
brand fragt ein wenig lächeln ist aber
mit so viel spannung spiel und mir war
es nie genau was ein hit wird und das
ist es nicht eigentlich nicht
weltmeister hin habe und sie sie kann
heute ihren einstand als kuratorin im
aargauer kunsthaus feiern
personen mit der eigentlich nicht die
wichtigste person es war um 15 und
künstler
ich glaube dass ich das vielleicht auch
um ständiges alten zeiten
verständigen
hier drinnen werden nun die
teilnehmenden der jahresausstellung
gebührend gefeiert und das ist gut so
wenn ihnen jetzt auch der sinn nach
regionaler kunst steht dann können sie
hierhin kommen nach aarau die
ausstellung läuft bis zum 6 januar
nächste woche trifft meine kollegin ina
mester zwei profis in sachen humor hey
burka und helge schneider
wenn das nicht lustig wird dann geht es
bei uns dieses jahr nichts mehr zu
lachen das ist nämlich der letzte
kulturplatz 2018
wir sehen uns wieder im kommenden jahr
und gleich jetzt vor ort und berichtet
über menschen mit down-syndrom die für
ihre rechte kämpfen unter dem titel wir
sind erwachsen
[Musik]
misumi